are you saying as a strategist around
social both of your problems are how do
I get customers to believe in the value
profit and then number two we've
actually get them how do I find people
to actually execute it cool so the
number one rule I have about sales is
not to convince anybody about anything I
have no interest in selling to you if
you don't believe so a lot of people try
to go and say hey Tony's pizza in
downtown you need social media you need
to do this you need to do this you do
this and Tony's like get the hell out of
here that's about where it ends for me I
have no interest in ever convincing any
money that what I'm doing is right
because I'd much rather spend all my
time on offense and none of it on
defense so I'd rather you turn around a
thousand stones than trying to dig
deeper under the 50 stones that you
turned over got it that's number one
number two you know I would be I think
what you should do is be knowledgeable
that who can do the things in your town
before you ever go to sell like you
should have a fairly good understanding
of the three Lance slash capabilities
and rolodex because if you walk in and
you start talking about turning over a
thousand stones like I told you to and
you get more yeses it's time to work so
I would highly recommend having that in
your pocket before you start